[Music]
cars schools hospitals artificial
intelligence and robotics are seeping
further and further into our lives
although they are convenient these new
technologies also raise a number of
legal and ethical questions these are
some of the challenges being brought to
light by the panel for the future of
science and technology of the European
Parliament stoah whose studies are
guiding MEP through the legislative
process we want a proposal on liability
evident example is in self-driving car
for the moment it's the driver who is
liable if there is an accident but if
I'm not driving anymore then of course I
cannot be liable for an accident caused
by my car and then in this case who is
liable is it a producer is it a software
provider is the network provider so
these questions have to be solved 75% of
EU citizens acknowledge the digital
technologies have a positive impact on
their quality of life but at the same
time 88% of those who find that the
newest technologies should be handled
with extreme care their concerns have
been taken up by MEP s who are calling
for an ethical charter or the creation
of a European agency for artificial
intelligence it will be tasked with
identifying any negative impact on
citizens and investigating possible
human rights violations expertise and
for the moment beta's expertise is in
the industry and I believe that as
consumer as policy maker we need
independent expertise so this is why I
say we would meet in your field agents
and so that Europe doesn't end up
lagging behind adequate financing for
the sector will also be crucial we need
a lot of money to invest because when
you see the money invested in China in
u.s. from private and public sites we
have big efforts to make to remain
competitive the European Commission
expects that private and public sectors
will invest 20 billion euros in the
robotic industry by 2020 and afterwards
more than 20 billion
year until 2030 ma bees want to
concentrate public support on strategic
sectors just health energy transport and
cybersecurity